avengers end game and star wars the rise
of skywalker were probably the most
anticipated movies of 2019
to varying degrees of success they
culminated in the end of a massive
saga that spanned multiple movies but i
have to say that whenever i watch the
rise of skywalker
i can't help but think that they ripped
off several moments in end game
and throughout this video we're going to
be examining certain scenes side by side
and discussing the similarities
to draw a conclusion over whether this
is the case or not
now obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if for some stupid
reason
you haven't watched some of the biggest
movies of all time then i recommend that
you turn off now
and sort your life out now make sure you
subscribe and the force will be with you
and please drop a thumbs up if you love
the channel 3000
without the way as always this is the
heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul now let's get into
our breakdown
okay so avengers end game currently
holds the spot as the highest grossing
movie of all time
though i think that the public
perception of it has slightly waned
since its release
no one can deny that it at least stuck
the landing and pulled off the
impossible task of wrapping up a 20 film
plus franchise with a sensational
send-off
i absolutely love the film and still get
goosebumps during its key scenes
i feel like it's the perfect closing of
the book on some incredible characters
juxtaposing this i left rise of
skywalker completely disappointed
and to me the film feels like it fumbles
the characters
has several logic leaps and just seems
so disjointed that it's up there
with probably my least favorite movies
in the saga but what went wrong
well the movie was darth plagueis with
issues
and after disney fired colin trevorrow
they returned to jj abrams in the hopes
of saving one of their tentpole
franchises
palpatine wasn't even supposed to be in
the film originally
and we know from recent interviews with
daisy ridley that she didn't even know
about being related to the character
up until the last minute the majority of
the final act was re-shot
and i believe that after the success of
endgame the creative team decided to
copy their comic book cousins
in order to emulate their triumph now
though i'll never be able to prove this
let's start at the top and go through
things now the last jedi and infinity
war
left the heroes feeling like they were
at a loss both the avengers and rebels
were almost wiped out by the antagonists
and this left them in a really
vulnerable position for the beginning of
the next movie
this often happens in film sagas and i
don't think that you can say it's
something that marvel really made up
however it's from these springboards
that things start to get closer in the
following films
now both endgame and ryze deal with an
enemy thought long
dead coming back from the grave in order
to quote unquote restore the universe
in endgame thanos is killed early on in
the movie
and after a huge five year time jump he
returns through time travel
with rise we see the return of emperor
palpatine a character thought long dead
who's returned through cloning
though i have no idea why i picked a
body with half the fingers missing
that looks like prince philip but never
mind now the heroes in the film have to
travel across time and space in order to
locate several mcguffins
to save the universe and may i'll let
them off for having
storylines in which they have to move
from from place to place
tracking down specific items those block
motifs pop up in a lot of films
but it's when we get into the final act
that things really start to become
really similar before we play the clips
though i just want to give a huge shout
out to youtube channel dim for putting
these edits together
and if you want to watch them without my
annoying accent then
they're linked in the description below
now the first scene in the finale deals
with the heroes being seemingly defeated
in end game it's after thor iron man and
captain america
have just been beaten by thanos and in
rise of skywalker it's after palpatine
has just taken down rey and wren
the villains in the piece both summon
their army and in
endgame we watches thanos's forces come
down from his ship
sanctuary two in rise of skywalker
palpatine star destroyers rise from the
planet
and this makes it seem like things
aren't going to be easy for the heroes
now in both scenes no matter what way
you look at it
there's one hero left standing both poe
and captain america
face almost insurmountable odds and they
stare out over the battlefield
looking completely defeated from here
one of the allies radios in
and then arrives with an entire fleet to
help out they even have a point where
john boyega and chadwick boseman rest in
peace appear on screen at the same time
i think it's almost shot for shot at
some point with several characters from
the franchises returning in order to
save the day
i'll i'll shut up for a second though
and let's play the clip so you can
decide for yourself
i'm sorry i thought we had a shot
there's just too many of them but there
are more of us
[Music]
look at this look at this
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
destroyers
so long sky trash
next is the big charge scene in which
the heroes
now united run at the enemy forces
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so i don't even think you can argue
that they're pretty much the exact same
moment
which in my opinion has been completely
copied by ryze
the heroes rush forward and we give
focus to several characters
as they charge at the antagonists though
the prior clip we showed
could be argued as just being a
coincidence i think when you see these
two in a row
it becomes so obvious and it gets worse
from there
[Music]
is
um
now in this scene we see the villain
unleashing their overpowered weapon
which completely decimates the entire
fleet of heroes
in endgame it's the guns on thanos's
ship and in rise it's palpatine's
lightning that brings down a multitude
of ships
there's even a crazy point in witcher
tornado and a bolt of lightning are shot
into the air
and in both versions one hero must step
forward in order to stop it from
destroying everything
this leads us into our next clip in
which one hero
faces down against the villain of the
piece and i think it's the most
obvious culprit in terms of copying
i am
[Music]
and i
i'm all the jedi
now yeah completely obvious and it's so
bad that when i was in the cinema i
could hear people laughing about it and
saying
i am iron man just before the line was
dropped by ray
the timing of the delivery is almost
beat for beat and the fact that these
lines are set up by
all the sith and inevitable jabs
delivered by the
villain i think is beyond ridiculous
this is pretty much the exact same scene
and when you learn about what the climax
was originally meant to be like
i think it becomes more and more obvious
that the team behind star wars attempted
to ape what they'd seen in endgame
originally the film was supposed to end
with rey actually seeing the jedi
and reportedly samuel l jackson hayden
christensen
and ewan mcgregor film things against
the green screen which would then be
dropped over the moment in which she
reaches out to the jedi
this scene is far too similar to not
have been deliberately done
especially when we know that the
majority of the reshoots for the finale
took place after endgame had been
released it's one of them ones that
if you were bothered about plagiarism
you would remove and reshoot and redo
as it's so similar that people would
obviously pick up on it
from here rise also echoes end game
massively
as the villain is then turned to dust as
are their forces
across the board we get this slime by
the hero and then their actions that
completely decimate the enemy's forces
but with endgame it makes sense because
we already know how the snap works
whereas with palpatine it doesn't make
that much sense
as only his troops are targeted those
are the most striking similarities i
think
and when they're all laid out side by
side it becomes obvious what happened
but why did disney do this especially
when they own the rights to both movies
well i think they're in lies the how and
why
disney were well aware that there would
be no legal repercussions for doing
something so similar
as it's not like marvel would sue
lucasfilm with them
being under the same corporation what i
think happened is that disney realized
that the rise of skywalker was a
complete disaster
due to its troublesome production
whether it's the firing of directors
the numerous script changes or the
insane amounts of backpedaling that they
had to do in order to fix the last jedi
things were always only gonna go one way
in the end i think that they panicked
and after seeing the success of endgame
they realized that in order to save one
of their highest grossing properties
they had to make things as similar as
they could to marvel
thus they ordered reshoots and placed in
rewrites that would be closer to
something that many fans viewed as the
best way to end a saga
though this makes sense on paper what
we're left with in my opinion is a film
that pales in comparison to the movie
that it's trying to emulate
and it speaks volumes to what things are
like at lucasfilm
the studio is often accused of dropping
the ball and having no real plan in
place
and i think this is further cemented by
the similarities that we've just
presented to you
i'm sure everyone is going to have an
opinion on this and some of you will
agree
whilst others won't all we can do is
present the evidence
give our thoughts and then let you make
your own mind up
but make sure you drop your conclusion
in the comments section below
i'd love to read it and if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the one division trailer
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over all the insane details so
definitely check it out after this
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of september so make sure
you get involved
you want to support the channel and get
to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace
you